Tenemos aquí 30x cuadrada más 11xy más "y" cuadrada
y lo que queremos hacer en este video es usar todo lo que ya sabemos
acerca de factorización de expresiones cuadraticas para factorizar esta expresión.
¿Ok? Entonces
yo te recomiendo que le pongas pausa a este video y trates de resolverlo tú solito por tu cuenta,
a ver si te pareció suficientemente
sencillo pero, bueno si te atoras mucho
entonces regresa y termina de ver este video. ¿Ok? Entonces
tenemos esta expresión y el truco aquí es reacomodar estos términos. Vamos a poner por aquí
"y" cuadrada más 11xy más 30x cuadrada y
la razón por la que los acomode de esta forma
es por que pues aunque aquí tenemos una expresión en términos de "x"
y pues en términos de "x" esto es una
cuadrática porque aquí estas dos cosas son un coeficiente
de "x" y esta cosa no depende de "x" en lo más mínimo.
Entonces esto se convierte en una cuadratica en términos de "x".
La forma en la que podemos pensar de esta forma es que si nosotros ya supiéramos exactamente
cuánto vale "y" o sea si "y" fuera un número fijo.
Entonces esto en realidad sí sería tal cual una expresión cuadratica sobre la variable "x".
Ahora lo reacomode  así por que esta expresión cuadratica tiene este coeficiente
al lado de la "x" cuadrada y esos, pues si hay una forma de factorizar estas expresiones
cuadráticas pero, todavía no lo hemos visto y es un poquito más complicado no mucho pero ligeramente. Sin embargo si
reacomodamos los términos y empezamos a considerar la variable "y"
entonces lo que tenemos es una expresión
cuadratica, cuyo coeficiente al lado de la "y" cuadrada es un 1 y esa si las podemos resolver así
rapidísimo. Ahora esta es una expresión
cuadrática en términos de la variable "y"
porque este último término no depende para nada de la variable "y" y aquí tenemos otro
coeficiente que multiplica a la "y" solita y pues aquí está la de cuadrada
entonces, si sabemos exactamente cuánto vale "x"
esto es una expresión cuadrática sobre la variable "y"
común y corriente. Vamos a tratar de resolverlo de la forma en la que hemos estado haciéndolo
últimamente en los últimos vídeos. ¿Ok? Estamos buscando 2 términos que cuando los multiplicamos
nos da 30x cuadrada pero que cuando lo sumamos
nos da 11x,
entonces ¿Cómo vamos a atacar ese problema de encontrar esas dos expresiones?
Pues podemos empezar por pensar en dos números que si los multiplicamos nos queda 30
pero que si los sumamos nos queda 11 entonces,
eso creo que ya lo hemos hecho si no en uno de los videos, en alguno de los ejercicios y pues podemos pensar en
5 con 6, 5 por 6 nos da 30
y 5 más 6 nos da 11
y bueno ¿Cómo llegamos a 5 y 6?
Pues es simplemente una cuestión de agarrar todos los pares de números que si los
multiplicamos nos da 30 y ver cuál de esos pares, si los sumamos, nos queda 11
¿Ok? Se puede resolver con
prueba y error y bueno, ya que tenemos
cuáles números si los multiplicamos nos da 30 y si los sumamos nos da 11,
ahora queremos que si los multiplicamos nos dé 30x cuadrada
y si lo sumamos nos dé 11x.
Entonces pues yo propongo que pongamos una "x" aquí y otra "x" por acá y
entonces si los multiplicamos nos queda 30x cuadrada y si los sumamos
5x más 6x pues si nos queda 11x.
Entonces lo que hemos visto de las ecuaciones cuadraticas nos dice que esta expresión es
exactamente igual a "y" más 5x por "y"  más 6x
y bueno, tú ahorita puedes agarrar y desarrollar esta multiplicación de binomios
y vas a ver que nos queda exactamente
30x cuadrada más 11xy más "y" cuadrada, pero el chiste es que ya terminamos de
factorizar esta expresión
utilizando únicamente lo que ya sabíamos hasta este momento.